i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle on a busy thursday night
big tech censorship it was kind of once
a relative rarity
but it's now increasingly commonplace
and the media once defenders of free
expression are cheering it on so tonight
we speak to the ceo of the federalists
and the managing editor of the babylon
bee now they've both seen their
companies targeted in just the last 24
hours also the bide administration very
petty demanding that georgia's senate
candidate and football legend herschel
walker
stepped down from the president's
council on sports fitness and nutrition
or be fired from the board herschel
walker is here later to respond
but first weak and wobbly that's the
focus of tonight's angle
with biden in europe today the world saw
an ineffective hesitant and dissembling
american president whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
no i'm thanking you
uh so someone haven't called on before
you
[Music]
who are you what was the first question
you're playing a game with me i'm not
supposed to say where i'm going am i
as the war on ukraine grinds on gas
prices skyrocket a global food shortage
looming joe biden had no answers and
like his supreme court nominee at a
confirmation hearing last week he gave a
lot of non-answers to important
questions like when he was pressed on
the upshot of his recent phone call with
china's president xi
namely the question was is china helping
the russian military
i
am not going to comment on any detail
about what we know or don't know
as a consequence of that conversation
but uh
tomorrow is
tomorrow or next monday that ursula's
having that conference with china
the first
on april 1st
translation let the eu handle it
they'll handle xi
i couldn't get anywhere with the guy
i mean how embarrassing biden obviously
couldn't get xi to agree to anything
regarding russia so now we're relying on
the europeans to figure things out
good luck with that
now world leaders especially our
adversaries listen intently to what an
american president has to say and biden
said several things today that were
absurd on their face
nato has never never been more united
than it is today we've built that same
unity with our european the european
union and with the leading democracies
of the g7
even the washington post had to concede
that nato is far from being unified
and france obviously didn't get that
unity memo either despite biden's call
to isolate putin economically
major french companies have just
announced that they're not cutting off
their business operations in russia at
all
now perhaps this is why biden is singing
a different tune on the power of
sanctions
let's get something straight sanctions
never deter
you keep talking about that
sanctions never deter
yeah just last month the white house
insisted that sanctions did serve an
important deterrence role
the president believes that sanctions
are intended to deter they're meant to
prevent and deter a large-scale invasion
of ukraine deter russia through
sanctions the sanctions are designed in
the first instance to try to deter
russia for taking further aggression
inconsistency is the only consistent
theme of this administration at this
point
now biden has made it clear that he's
content to let other nations lead on
ukraine on energy and pretty much
everything else
but when all else fails and all else is
failing with biden
old joe returns to his greatest hits
trump
and charlottesville
i had no intention of running for
president again
and until i saw
those folks coming out of the fields in
virginia carrying torches and carrying
nazi banners and literally
singing the same
vile
rhyme that they used in germany in the
early 20s or 30s i should say
and um
and then when
the gentleman you mentioned was asked
what he thought and a young woman was
killed a protester he said they're very
good people on both sides
this framing has been debunked so many
times it's not even worth addressing it
again
but biden didn't stop there using a
foreign reporter's question to once
again tee off on the united states while
standing abroad
my focus of any election is on making
sure that we retain the house in the
united states senate
so that i have the room to continue to
do the things that i've been able to do
in terms of grow the economy and deal
in a rational way with american foreign
policy and
lead the world lead be the leader of the
free world i say to people at home
imagine if we sat and watched the
the doors of the bundestag broken down
and
police officers killed and hundreds of
people storming in or imagine if we saw
that happening in the british parliament
or whatever how would we feel
even for biden this is a new low
giving the impression that america is
filled with torch carrying nazis ready
at any moment to storm the capital
why would europe want the president of
the united states of
that america to lead the way on anything
they wouldn't
this is just a bad version of what obama
though did in 2009 remember when he
sucked up to europe by talking down his
own country
in america there's a failure to
appreciate europe's leading role in the
world
instead of celebrating your dynamic
union and seeking to partner with you
to meet common challenges
there have been times where america has
shown arrogance
and been dismissive
even derisive
naturally the press loved that because
he was a citizen of the world
europe knew obama signaled weakness and
today we're even weaker with obama's old
vp in charge
putin's targeting civilians and american
families can't afford food and gas
and biden's acting like an msnbc pundit
by feeding russia and china
anti-american propaganda yeah that
happened today
this entire trip to brussels was just a
waste of jet fuel
biden should have just participated over
zoom or something would have been easier
the man's incoherent enough without jet
lag how do you think he was with jet lag
well you saw it
how pathetic to see an american
president make false claims about nato
unity while sowing division and disunity
at home
everything biden touches though falls
apart doesn't it including his
disastrous foreign policy
americans aren't used to seeing their
commander-in-chief as an observer on the
world stage
no matter what you thought of trump he
was the lead dog in every fight
and the latest polls suggest that
americans aren't loving biden's lead
from behind strategy a grinnell college
poll pegged his approval rating at 34
only 37 supported his handling of the
situation in ukraine and a new emerson
poll has biden trailing donald trump and
a head-to-head matchup by three points
if he thinks these appearances on the
world stage are somehow going to boost
him
he's got another thing coming
it's a good time to remember that biden
from the moment he was elected
europe breathed a sigh of relief knowing
that it didn't have to deal with trump
flexing on them any longer
after all trump demanded so much of
europe
more trade reciprocity more military
spending
of course they had to honor their nato
commitments and no nordstream 2 pipeline
oh no
but in biden they know they have a
debilitated american leader who values
collectivism over national sovereignty
and of course globalization above
everything else
the rest of the world along with the us
media have waited for this moment for
really over 30 years
because ever since reagan left office
the global elites have dreamed of a
weaker america
a humbler america an america that will
do what it's told
obama sacrificed his entire presidency
to that concept which is why trump came
along and won in 2016.
but after 2020 with biden in the white
house the americans were supposed to
just behave themselves be obedient to
this new international order and then
all would be calm
well
how's that working out so far and that's
the angle